the world of Tron is massive the scope
of this movie is infinite a lot of
different environments I really wanted
to scream to be like a window into
another world in order to fully
experience Tron the way it's intended
it's great to see it on the biggest
screen possible well film starts as a 2d
film in the real world but once Sam
Flynn is pulled into the world of Tron
the film transitions into a 3d movie
IMAX for 3d particularly it's a great
format because IMX
uses one projector for each eye so you
get double the brightness and you create
a bright vivid image in 3d the sound
system and every IMAX theatre is
calibrated to give the best optimum
sound change the scheme alter the mood
electrify the boys and girls if you'd be
so kind
the soundtrack by deaf Punk was recorded
and mixed in surround sounds to get an
incredible sound and obviously the size
of the screen which is just the most
immersive vast experience for an IMAX
theater strong legs
we'll go to a special larger format
expanding on screen for seven sequences
for a total of 43 minutes of the film
self the screen will get even larger
vertically to create even a bigger frame
and for a movie like Tron Legacy it's
the perfect fit